it's no secret that all of us get
anxious before giving an interview
however your confidence boosts up when
you prepare for the interview well
even the smartest job seeker needs to
prepare well
so here we are to help you with that
today we bring you this interesting
video on interview tips for the year
2021
apart from your technical questions many
questions are asked
which can make or break your future
these questions might seem easy but they
are not
and the answer to these can be tricky
and do more harm than good
so the better prepared you are the more
successful your interview will be
this video will help you understand what
an interviewer is looking for in your
answers
teach you to answer interview questions
and convince the hiring manager that you
are
a good fit for the job so first and
foremost
before you step into the interview make
sure that you have carried out good
research about the company
this will help you get an insight into
what the company is all about and helps
you answer better
doing your research beforehand will also
make a much better impression on the
hiring manager
you can start by visiting the company's
website have a look at their service
mission statement and the company's
culture you can also glance through the
company's social media accounts
additionally you could also use google
news to stay updated with the company's
current situation
the next point is to keep in mind to
ensure that your skills are aligned with
the job description
it would be good if you understand what
the employer is looking for
think about examples from your work
history and match them with the
requirements
this will make it simpler for the
employer to understand that you are a
good fit for the applied job role
if in case you lack any of the required
skills you can mention that you are
working on it and in no time you will
master it
on the day of the interview make sure
that you are dressed professionally
be comfortable in your attire and it is
advised that you look at the company's
dress code policies
you can also choose a professional
outfit like business casual
formals and a comfortable pair of formal
footwear you need to look
presentable our next tip is to have good
body language
body language is also another way of
communication
when you walk into the interview room
confidently greet with a firm handshake
and eye contact
while you take a seat keep in mind to
sit up straight
you must have good posture and not
slouch speaking of gestures try not to
touch your face too much
avoid a tense impression with your hands
and keep your hands on your lap
or the table hands on the table and a
gentle lean will emphasize that you
are listening carefully your body
language should be very respectful
be aware of your movements and stay calm
through the course of the interview
now let me brief you on answering a few
of the most frequently questions in an
interview
number one tell me about yourself this
question is asked to get your confidence
and communication skills
here you can speak about education
experience and hobbies
make sure to have a concise answer and
answer with enthusiasm
two what are your strengths and
weaknesses through this answer the
interviewer wishes to see how positive
you think about yourself
and if you can identify your weaknesses
speaking about your strengths
there's no right or wrong it can be
about your flexibility
your attention to detail and so on
however
speaking about your weaknesses you don't
have to be hard on yourself
you can reply with an answer like your
attention to detailed trait can
sometimes be a disadvantage
and you tend to spend more time this way
your weakness still has a positive side
three where do you see yourself in the
next five years this question can be a
little tricky
through this question the interviewer is
analyzing your commitment to the company
an ideal answer to this would be to tell
how you wish to be a significantly
higher position in the future
and learn new things four why should we
hire you
when answering this question do not
speak about how good your academics are
instead speak about how eager you are to
learn
and hence the opportunity would be a
good one to show your zeal
you can also touch upon a few qualities
that they have that will be highly
beneficial for this job
you can also list a few positive impacts
you have made in the previous
organization
and how you can bring those here five
finally the interviewer might conclude
by asking you if you have any questions
for them always make sure to ask good
and relevant questions
this displays the seriousness you have
towards the job ask
questions regarding opportunities for
your professional development in the
particular job role
it is important to know that this is for
your personal growth
based on this you can decide if that
particular job is a good choice for your
career or not
these were a few of the commonly asked
questions in an interview
whenever you're asked a question it is
good to pause and think about it before
responding
make sure your answers are concise to
the point and honest
if there comes a confusing question do
not hesitate to ask
more clarification given the current
scenario with the ongoing pandemic kovid
19
everything is digital that applies to
interviews
as well many companies are currently
taking virtual interviews for hiring
purposes
a virtual interview takes place remotely
over video conferences
in addition to the already discussed
tips let's have a look at a few more
tips that can help you carry out your
virtual
interview smoothly firstly have a good
internet connection which can facilitate
video conferences
it is advised that you are familiar with
the platform on which that interview is
carried out
like zoom microsoft teams etc by doing
so you won't have to be worried about
the platform's technicalities on the day
of the interview itself
next make sure that you are seated in a
quiet place
eliminate any potential interruptions on
your end before the interview
have a good set of microphones to have a
clear audio quality
while talking make sure to look into
your computer's camera and not the
screen
in case of any network issues and lags
make sure you politely ask the
interviewer to repeat the question and
politely repeat your answer if you are
asked to
so that brings us to the end of this
video on interview tips
i hope these tips are helpful to all you
job seekers out there
and i wish you all the very best thank
you for watching the video
and stay tuned for more from simply
learn